[Music]
so
[Music]
please
about the issues that matter to you most
tonight after two years of lockdowns
restrictions and isolation orders the
government says it's time to live with
rather than fight against the cobit 19
virus
but can life ever really be the same
again
i'm trevor phillips and this is the
great debate
[Applause]
each week we get to the heart of the
issue dominating the headlines
tonight as the queen is treated for
kobit 19 and the government announces
self-isolation rules and free testing
are coming to an end
our viewers panel from across the
country will tell their stories they'll
have their say and they'll hold our
studio guest to account
joining us this week professor asuagani
chair in infectious disease epidemiology
at imperial college london
the chef and restaurateur aldo zilli
harriet minter
journalist and author of specializing in
women's rights and the future of work
and lord sumption former justice of the
supreme court
the question facing us all tonight
are you ready to live with covid it is
time that we got our confidence back we
don't need laws to compel people to be
considerate to others
i must give the british people a very
simple instruction you must stay at home
it is so important that people stay at
home
i'm not allowed
hello
it's the first time lorraine's seen her
mum this year a change in the rules
means the limit on visitor numbers will
be lifted
live from windsor with breaking news as
the queen tests positive for covid19 the
word covid sets a bit of a shudder she
is only suffering mild cold like
symptoms
i am quietly confident i think this is
the beginning of the end i'm terrified
to be honest the risk of covid hasn't
changed you know it's still a threat to
my life
we now be able to begin a new chapter
learning to live with cobin after two of
the darkest grimmest years in our
peacetime history i do believe this is a
moment of pride for our nation
let's start as always with our viewers
panel i'd like to talk to imogen dempsey
imagine you're in london
hi
good evening
what do you think
i'm very worried as to why the
government is ignoring the science
british medical association and nhs
leaders and the world health
organization have all said it's too soon
to be lifting restrictions the removal
of free testing is leveling down on
public health this is a really really
concerning measure there are 3.7 million
vulnerable people
there's a lot of us and a lot of friends
and family
scrapping the free testing and
doing that is just absolutely appalling
it leaves us even more vulnerable
and when you say vulnerable imaging in
your case what does that mean what level
of risk do you think you face in terms
of my vulnerability unfortunately i've
got no antibodies from my first two
doses of vaccine i'm not sure about
following the booster but that was over
10 weeks ago so that will be waning
we are talking here about lives and
livelihoods for vulnerable people
because many vulnerable people are being
asked to return to workplaces
where there's now no protections in
place and somebody who is positive
will be permitted under these new rules
to go in and if you've got vulnerable
kids they will be in classrooms with
positive people and potentially bringing
it home that's obviously you know a
hugely increased risk for everybody and
particularly for vulnerable people
thank you um let's talk to paul johnston
paul
you're in stafford i believe
that's right what how do you respond to
what you've heard from prime minister
today
i think it's fantastic news i think
we're at a tipping point where as the
lady just said just uh 85 have had both
doses
91
have had one dose
i think 66 percent of the population
have been boosted so we now need to move
on uh and push this great country on
azerogany um
what do you think
there's there clearly is are two ways of
looking at this where do you stand well
i mean it's very challenging and there
isn't a single science that we can
follow we're all learning as scientists
as well as the wider health community um
but there are basic premises in public
health and the first is that prevention
is always better than a cure so anything
we can do to protect people to prevent
them getting infected in the first place
is valuable and in the longer term is
also cost effective so i do feel very
strongly that testing is an integral
part of that
both allowing individuals to know their
status and make appropriate decisions
themselves but also as a community and
as a population as a whole that testing
system is really fundamental to
surveillance to us knowing when the new
variants emerge and being able to assess
as rapidly as possible if they are of
concern all right i'm going to come back
to you in a second let me just go to
back to our panel because i think phil
eagle i think uh phil you're in dublin
you've got a question for our panel
thanks travia um
we've spent the past two years being
told that as a
all the decisions are being made by
following the science
uh i'd just like to know what science
we're following now to lift the
restrictions so quickly
and your question phil
panel
if we've been following science for two
years
what science are we following now that
restrictions are being lifted
back again i mean again it's it's very
challenging to pinpoint one bit of
science what we're learning all the time
is how good the vaccines are they're
really central to us controlling this
disease and and moving on with our lives
and we do have the new therapeutics
however i think most scientists strongly
believe in testing and strongly believe
in the principle of allowing people who
have symptoms or test positive to
self-isolated if they can
now of course people can take their own
responsibility for that but that's not
always possible if individuals have to
go to work and don't feel they can make
that decision themselves then i think we
lose some of the public health response
that's so critical so you would still be
leading towards sustaining
uh free testing uh incentives to more
testing than where the prime minister uh
set out today yeah absolutely in fact as
the uk is probably the world leading in
terms of the testing that's available
and in terms of the surveillance so
people are following
our science um to see what's happening
with the new variants understand them so
this testing system is really critical
lord sampson do you agree
as regarding says protect
i think that that's an important factor
but it isn't the only one
i think the problem about this whole
argument
about following the science is that it
is not just a scientific issue
it's it is a an economic issue
it's a social issue it's an educational
issue it's a moral issue
and it's always a matter for political
judgment uh what weight you give to each
of those factors
uh it would be quite wrong for the
government to be guided only by the
science
there have been periods in the last two
years when they have been periods when
they haven't it is about time that we
looked at this very complicated problem
in the round instead of just the
scientific aspect of it but what about
uh ghana's basic point that before you
get to any judgment precautionary
principle if i remember it from my from
my laboratory days
first thing is
i'm not a fan of the precautionary
principle the precautionary principle is
essentially a principle
for taking action when you don't have
the evidence to justify it but think you
might have later now that's fine
for some uh interventions but if you are
going to do to have an intervention
which causes great damage or costs a
great deal of money then it seems to me
that it can never be good enough simply
to say we don't know the answer uh and
therefore we're going to act as if we
did
all right i'm going to come back to you
in a moment but let's go back to vr's
panel and let's talk to
jan boyd
i personally am at a bit of a crisis
point i'm still wearing a mask when i go
out my social life has been very curved
and i'm uh i'm just concerned about this
uh freedom day and let's get back to
normal and i feel like sometimes we're
on an edge and we're gonna fall off and
i'm not quite certain what the long
long-term ramifications of that are
going to be
okay joan
harriet minter
you are have some vulnerability to cope
with yourself
what do you think
so i really empathize actually with what
john's saying there because i
i feel that sort of double bind as well
this desire to
have a life as we remember it this
desire to be out and to be meeting
people to have a social life and also
this desire to take a level of personal
responsibility to say actually
i don't want to pass something on to my
parents i don't want to pass it on
somebody else who's clinically extremely
vulnerable
and as someone who does have a health
condition which makes me more vulnerable
to covet
am concerned that perhaps other people
are not going to take those precautions
that perhaps people will say well i used
to be able to get a test for free but
now i can't and
it doesn't mean it's all fine doesn't
that mean it's gone away and i think
what's worrying
in the messaging we're seeing at the
moment is this idea of freedom day as
they're actually taking care of each
other for the past two years being
responsible for each other for the past
two years was a bad thing as opposed to
something we should really be trying to
do as a society what's that thing they
say where you measure the quality of the
society by the care it takes of its most
vulnerable that's what we should be
thinking prime minister says we should
trust people now i mean we should but
then we looked at our prime minister who
went wandering around you know hospitals
shaking hands with everybody paying no
attention to the science and taking no
cautions whatsoever so i'm not sure he
is the best example yeah
although zilli um
we could pay attention to the needs of
the vulnerable and so on but
you run businesses
there's a price
listen
uh whatever you know the prime minister
is the prime minister we should listen
to the prime minister should we he's in
charge of the country and he hasn't done
a terrible job so far
and today
he's lifted everything completely so
we're going to be free again
and
if you ask me
i
i don't think it's quite right that he's
going to take away
the taste
taste and trace thing
but
as a country we need the economy to
go back up again as the hospitality
industry has been on its knees for the
last two years
uh we need people to go out to work and
by them going out to work they'll come
to our restaurants and uh you know it
it's uh
it's something that yeah i i champion um
it's a judgment but you say in a sense
we've got to open up
all right let's come back to jump in the
economy
okay let's come back to
our
viewers panel go to the wall ayesha
hennessey
what do you do
um
well my personally i i work with a very
vulnerable section of
society that are addicted to illicit
substances and alcohol
and
from what i've seen over the last two
years has had a detrimental effect on
their mental health and um i i do
believe you know a lot of these people
haven't got um even you know electronic
devices to to to reach out to people
they haven't got family they haven't got
friends they haven't got a lot of
connections
and it's um definitely had a detrimental
effect on their mental health their
well-being you know developing symptoms
like anxiety
um you know we've also had people that
are quite isolated and had to work from
home over the last two years who have
developed addictions
uh people that we don't usually see
coming through the door um
who who have now got you know uh
alcohol problems substance use problems
you know uh over-the-counter medication
issues so
i think you know it's had a real effect
on um society that
piece of society that usually wouldn't
be affected in this way or wouldn't have
that's very very helpful thank you stay
there
as regarding um
you rightly set this out as a it's a
difficult judgment
and you lean towards
as i said the precautionary principle
but you hear from aldo zilli the impact
on the economy
you hear from aisha hennessy
the impact on mental health that there
are costs both ways can you see that the
costs of not opening up might be greater
i would first say what we're talking
about here is not whether we're opening
up the economy again what testing
does is allows people to make those
decisions to test before they go to the
restaurant um to to test if they feel
concerned about their health
and then to go to the workplace feeling
more comfortable and more confident that
they are indeed safe so i i don't think
that's that's the balance here i suspect
most of this is really related to the
economic cost of testing but i would
remind everyone that the cost of testing
depends on the level of transmission if
we have transmission at a much lower
level the cost will come down there'll
be fewer cases to test
okay well let's see
how this discussion
has
shaped the view of our wall of our
viewers panel i'm going to put everybody
a question to you and i want uh some
hands up one of the government's main
announcements today was an end to the
requirement to self-isolate
if you test positive for covid so um
what do you think should people still
have to stay at home
if they have coronavirus raise your hand
if you think people should still have to
self-isolate if they have coronavirus
okay uh joe hold your hands this let's
see
yeah actually
just a bit more than half we're thinking
think that um self-isolation should stay
lord assumption
um well the way you put the question i
think somewhat invited that answer
um
the that that's a that's a lawyer's
response but anyway they know what i
mean okay
i'm sure they do um
i think that there's one aspect of this
which no one's mentioned so far which is
that we are not in the same situation
that we were a year ago or a year and a
half ago
the levels of vaccination are extremely
high
or micron is much more infectious than
previous variants but
it is now absolutely clear that the
symptoms are much milder the the
proportion of confirmed cases that get
hospitalized
is less than two percent at the moment
uh the um
the treatments available are much better
this is not as serious a problem as it
previously was and we're entitled to
take a different balance of risks now
than we would have been half half a year
ago all right
we are going to continue
with the great debate up next we're
living with covid help or hinder the
pressures on the nhs
hospitals in lincolnshire have declared
a critical incident because so many
people are off work after testing
positive we simply don't have the
capacity in the nhs that we need you can
just get one qualified nurse sometimes
on the ward
it's absolutely ridiculous
[Applause]
we started naming storms in 2015 we've
never had three in a week last monday we
named two on the same day we've never
done that before either so yes uh it's
been a very very active week of weather
and so we're seeing further impacts from
these storms this morning uh storm
franklin the latest one to hit of course
and really strong gusts overnight
particularly northern ireland and
northwest england areas that weren't uh
as badly affected by storm units on
friday so each storm is different each
of these three storms has affected
different parts of the uk in different
ways but each of them are providing some
pretty serious issues as they've moved
across the country i think the winds
were forecast pretty much were as
expected so the winds that we were
predicting came to fruition that's what
we saw and i think one of the things
that
meant that we didn't have as much uh
disruption perhaps was because we named
it on monday and then we gave people
four days notice so spreading the word
about this storm that was incoming
actually helped people prepare for it so
train companies were able to to you know
adjust their timetables in accordance
and the energy companies were able to
make preparations ahead as well so
that's part of it i think we were able
to name the storm give four days uh
notice and that really helped uh
mitigate the the situations but the
winds were pretty much as expected and
structures get weakened by each of these
storms that move across of course so uh
because we're you know these warnings
are impact-based it's always
hard to say exactly what impacts we're
going to see from from any individual
storm but of course as storm dudley
moves through that does weaken
structures that then could get broken or
or damaged by storm munis and then the
third one coming in now storm franklin
hitting bringing again very strong winds
and those winds are likely going to
cause more damage because storm munis
has been through as well so yes the
succession of storms likely to increase
the problems and of course they all
bring more rain with them as well and
that's what we've seen now storm
franklin that although rain and flooding
wasn't such an issue with eunice or
dudley it is now becoming more of an
issue as well
[Music]
[Applause]
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
this is the great debate
are you ready to live with covid
all areas of life been affected by the
pandemic but probably none more so than
the health service
waiting lists are at record highs staff
are under huge pressures and many
treatments have been delayed
let's hear firsthand experience from one
of our viewers panel
mandy wren you're in ferum
yeah can you talk to us about uh what
you've experienced in the last
18 months two years
yeah so um in march 2020 just ahead of
the um
first lockdown my hodgkin's lymphoma
cancer relapsed in a very serious and
aggressive way and i think at the time
it was clear that
the strain of the nhs meant that cancer
treatment was going to have to be
prioritized towards those people that
were going to benefit from the treatment
so it was very very frightening for
myself and my family but luckily i i i
went forward with my treatment which
worked
a friend of mine at the same time he was
told that if he hadn't had his treatment
life-saving treatment a week before
lockdown he would have not had it and he
would have died
so this is still really serious stuff
and i'm really worried that
continuing strain on um the nhs will
mean that there's still ongoing
prioritization um and i'm not just
singling out cancer i'm talking about
the millions and millions of extremely
vulnerable people
and
if we don't have testing
if we don't monitor this disease
if people think that it's like a cold
and they're just wandering around and
they don't think that they need to
self-isolate then people like myself and
the lady earlier on
we're probably going to have to be
prioritized um and that's what i'm
really worried about
hold on there for a moment man i want to
ask rachel dambrosio
um
about her experience yeah so my story is
that in september 2020 i went to a e i
was in extreme abdominal pain i was
literally crying in pain and
they totally misdiagnosed me and i ended
up when i came out i knew that i just
had to get seen somewhere so i ended up
going private and two days later i had a
private ultrasound and saw a private
consultant and was told that i had
severe endometriosis
and i needed a total urgent hysterectomy
and that the endometriosis was literally
strangling my bowels and i ended up
having a private laparoscopy because of
the weights of the on the nhs to
actually get a laparoscopy and if i
hadn't have done that i totally believe
that if i hadn't have lost my life i
probably would have lost my bowels what
what concerns me about this whole about
what happened to me is that
is this the way is the government
actually trying to force us into a
two-tier health system where if you can
afford to go private you have to go
private and if you can't you have to
stick with the nhs
i see uh you've got uh sure you've got a
question for our studio panel here
rachel what's about the nhs
it is yes so my question is how much
stress will living with kovid actually
put on the hospitals and the nhs because
it's already under stress at the moment
so it's just going to put it under more
stress in my opinion
thank you rachel thank you mandy
great question for our panel
how much stress will living with kovid
put on our hospitals and nhs
and lord assumption i guess uh the
underlying question is that can it cope
well the very low proportion
of confirmed cases that are now being
hospitalized um certainly suggests that
it can it can cope this is a much
milder variant but i think we've also
got to bear in mind uh that the uh
the
problems about particularly cancer but
also
other illnesses
have arisen partly from the demands on
hospitals from covid itself and partly
have been the effect of some of the more
extreme measures particularly locked
down
a very significant increase
in cancer deaths is likely to have
resulted
from the number of untreated or
undiagnosed cancers particularly
at the earlier stage
of the pandemic other diseases
like
dementia for example which is
traditionally been much the largest
killer in the united kingdom
have gone through the roof as a result
of the counter measures taken to control
the pandemic so i mean this is actually
not a simple one-way option it's
undoubtedly right that the more beds are
taken up by covid uh patients the fewer
beds are are available for other people
but the damaging consequences have also
been produced by the government's
countermeasures all right let's um i
mean we could no doubt spend the whole
evening arguing about statistics but i
think your your point is uh broadly made
and i'm going to come back to azurgan in
a second but mandy um
what do you think about lord sumption's
view that actually
the counter measures
to covid may have been a contributor to
the sort of problem that you outlined
i don't i don't necessarily disagree
with him but i just
what i'm worried about is that as we
sort of move forward with this
view that we are now free that we the
pandemic is not is over it is not over
it is not over
this is going to continue and hard
choices are going to have to be made by
people
and i'm going to stay everybody in the
eye and go this could be me i could be
dead in a year
because there's not enough capacity in
the nhs and you've all seen me on these
on this panel sorry to be provocative
but that's how i feel so there's no
point shaking your head and going that's
not true
it is true
as agony
you worry about the numbers you're an
epidemiologist what do you make of this
no i think their points are very valid
and of course um as we've heard there
was an immense stress put on the nhs and
i think the nhs and all their staff have
done an amazing and fantastic job in
coping in really such exceptional
circumstances and they're to be
commended for this
if we can keep covet at a low level then
we won't have to worry about the impact
that covert is having on the nhs because
it won't be having that impact but what
we absolutely can't do is say
we have omicron at the moment it's all
mild it's all gone away what we do know
for certain is there will be another
variant it is likely to be a variant
that has some degree of escape from the
vaccines otherwise it couldn't
sustain itself and we cannot be certain
it is going to be as mild as omicron so
therefore surveillance and testing is
central to us knowing that and
preventing a build up in the future of
the pressures that the nhs has
experienced so far okay harriet minter
i actually um i felt quite emotional
listening to the two women speak there
because i had a similar experience i
ended up in a e in november 2020 and
felt like i was being a bit ridiculous
felt that i was taking up nhs resources
at a terrible time and actually ended up
probably kind of hours away from death
and
survived because of the nhs because i
had access to it because they are
really the backbone of our society and i
everything that we say about how we
protect them feels incredibly important
to me because they protect us
and i think when we forget that where we
end up in is a situation where we were
pre-covered where we take it for granted
where we chronically underfund it and
where we leave our nhs weakened so that
when things like over do happen it is a
massive pressure on them and it
shouldn't be
and that's what we need to be thinking
about right now we need to be thinking
about as azeroth says how do we keep
covert levels low so that we don't add
to that pressure and how do we ensure
that we are not in this situation again
where our nhs is already straining at
the seams
before
a crisis hits let's come back to uh our
wall and i want to talk to pastor
mick fleming um good evening
pastor mick you deal
with uh i think a lot of people who
need these services what do you
reckon about the nhs kapati to cope
it's a real struggle
uh
we're trying to get people out with the
mental health
uh we can't get it
people are losing their lives because of
it
i'm personally taking people to hospital
in the car they can't get seen
you can't get online appointments i've
got people with gangrene in their legs
and they can't get the legs dressed uh i
could go on and on and on
the uh the lockdown
uh restrictions have
have caused
devastation that's there's no data about
that
but i think if you take testing away
then you take choice away because if you
don't know you've got it and you're
wandering around and you're not going to
test yourself you don't have a choice do
you and
it just seems ridiculous i think it
seems for what i hear it just like some
of these guys from the politicians
they're living in houses with no windows
they don't see what's going on outside
uh the consequences of what we're
talking about is death
and in the poorer areas and the poorer
parts of the country death on a mass
scale i've never seen anything like it
when i'm witnessing that
it's horrendous
it's horrendous
all right uh thank you uh mick fleming
aldo zilli um i guess if a government
minister were here he or she would say
we're increasing taxes
putting
one quarter percent on national
insurance
we're going to raise 12 billion a year
and it's going into the nhs to help
solve these
problems
is that enough
well i suppose it is but
increasing taxes and increasing national
insurance like it's going to be and
obviously um
interest rates are going to go up uh
the standard leaving is going to be more
expensive you know we we're going we're
gonna have to pay more for everything
but the brexit as well uh hasn't helped
at all
uh we've had
two years i'm talking about my industry
we've had two years of
closure and opening closing opening
closing and
nobody's fault you know i mean there was
a pandemic
but i think now
is the time
for everyone to get positive there's a
lot of mental health problems in my
industry as well with chefs and
waiters and people that haven't been
able to work and or they had two jobs or
they had they had no jobs thank you very
much
coming up what will living with kovid
look like for children and young people
that's next
when the pandemic struck young people
saw a huge disruption an ayat is from
london and was due to sit his a-levels
this is the first bit of sunshine i've
experienced in a few weeks i want him to
go back to school because i don't want
to do home school i don't think that
they should be going back i'd rather
homeschool him we don't really know
what's going on with our lives
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate
where this week we're asking
are you ready to live with covid let's
go back to our viewers panel and talk to
helen pryor we've talked a lot so far
about uh vulnerable people and how
there's vulnerable people in society
well
both my children are classed as
clinically vulnerable from the start of
the pandemic because they have a medical
condition called pounds pandas which is
an autoimmune condition
and i'd just like to highlight to
everybody that
covet is not the only virus that we live
with
there are hundreds of diseases many of
which are highly contagious and
it's nice to know if somebody's
contagious in a classroom but unless
we're gonna start testing for cold flu
tonsillitis scarlet fever chickenpox
it's pointless testing for covid because
actually if you've got a vulnerable
child
they are vulnerable medically vulnerable
to lots of conditions and unfortunately
what we've found is
uh
lockdowns bubble closures isolating
teachers and classmates
it's actually impacted my children
more than the virus
helen i'm guessing that is indeed one of
your children sitting with you
it is this is evie yes
evie um
how's it felt to you
missing school through lockdowns has
been a main issue for me
when i started to get better
it locked down just hit
and then anxiety impacted me going back
to school and then when i got back to
school
things would be unsure and classmates
and teachers would be off so that
impacts me a lot more than the virus
itself
thank you so much both of you let's talk
to a teacher tarek ali
um
good evening good evening good evening
uh there's a suggestion there that
actually
what what we've had to do to tackle
covid has had
at least as big an effect on children as
cobit itself
it's been absolutely horrendous for
teachers and especially for the pupils
for about two years now the teachers
have been absolutely instrumental in
supporting all vulnerable pupils and
their families through online learning
it's not just been the pupils we've been
supporting family members as well
teachers have had to learn how to do
this without any notice without any
training we were sent home on a friday
from monday you're going to be online
many pupils had no access to computers
at home and they've missed out missed
about two years worth of their vital
education
i would say that teachers have been
unsung heroes throughout the pandemic
but my question to the panel is
is it now time to prioritize children
and young people after two years of
looking after other groups
thank you so much tarek
tara's question for
you and i guess rest of the country is
is it time now to prioritize children
and young people after two years of
looking after other groups aldo
well yes
i totally agree with that i've got a 13
year old and a 16 year old
two teenagers and a 39 year old
obviously i started young
but
my
16 year old
and my 13 year old when we um when the
pandemic really hit us
i got them into work
i got them into work in the kitchen with
me
we started doing deliveries together we
started cooking food for the
neighborhood
we cooked food for the nhs together
uh so i could keep them busy because
there i could see that it was affecting
them
the i was more worried about their
mental state because they couldn't go to
school they couldn't see their friends
and uh that affected them uh in a in a
big way
especially my son he's a footballer and
uh that had to stop
uh sport it's a big thing for him
my daughter um
you know twiggy is 13 and
she was very vulnerable so i got them
both um busy okay harriet you're you're
closer well you are a young person um
have you know sympathy for people of my
vintage oh i have lots of sympathy
i'm thrilled you think i'm a young
person though that's the highlight of my
day um i think i have a lot of friends
with young children very young children
some of whom were born during lockdown
and certainly what they are worried
about is the social skills those
children are missing out on the
connections they could be making and the
kind of very important learning that
happens at a young age and i i do think
we need to be aware of that and aware of
the impact it's having on those children
however what i also hear them constantly
complaining about is the second one
child in the school one child in the
class gets covered a week later the
entire class has coveted it is
incredibly contagious we know that and
so while yes we need to be prioritizing
young people's lives and getting them
back to living their lives we also need
to be aware of the facts that their
lives are probably not going to look
like ours did and we need to help them
understand that all right mohammed walji
uh you have a thought on this point
yeah hiya so um i'm currently studying
my a levels which i'll take in the
summer
and i'm part of the first cohort to not
set any formal exams our gcses were
cancelled two years ago
and we're going into the
a levels pretty much blind without
having much prior knowledge
and there's so many questions that have
been raised by the lifting of the
lockdown today for example when we do go
to our exam
what if we have covered will we have to
isolate
and covert hasn't just
affected our past it's also affecting
our future in that way
you've probably had
a lot of teenagers uh coming into uh
your college in the last couple of years
what what
what difference have you seen with them
and do you have um sympathy with what
muhammad is saying oh absolutely and i
think we always have to prioritize the
young people it's been very challenging
to do that so far in the pandemic but i
think at least over the last year their
lives have been prioritized and we
certainly have the same issue with
students everything in terms of the
teaching had to go online very very
rapidly and it's very difficult for
young people um to be working in that
manner not interacting with each other
not getting the experience um that they
would expect from education so i think
we do prioritize that and actually
within our college we keep testing in
place to ensure that we can have a safe
environment for in-phase teaching
all right
after a break we'll be finding out what
changes from the last two years our
viewers and panel want to carry on
and what things they'll never do again
it's so good to see you deciding you're
having so much fun wasn't it yeah i
think people just needed that to be able
to hear somebody know that they're not
on their own people are at home they
want content they need to stay fit and
inspired in the midst of lockdown it was
a personal challenge that became a
national triumph
[Music]
big stories don't always come from big
cities
i'm lisa dowd and i'm skye's midlands
correspondent and this is where i grew
up
we can reveal that the driver who hit
harry dunn is 42 year old and sakulas
just met the president and
we never thought we'd get this far
this is what they're up against that the
wind is the really big problems it is
back-breaking work and the smoke is
thick
it's been working well water levels are
dropping but no one knows what impact
further rain will have
what would you do if this place wasn't
open
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
it's really scary we're terrified
in this community i'm told that
everybody knows someone affected by
covid hopefully this will be the last
wave
i never knew they would make it it's
amazing
change seems tantalisingly close in this
corner of the uk wales was the first to
introduce the plastic bag charge
this is my patch my specialism it's also
my home
[Music]
i'm hinderman rasheed and i'm sky's
north of england correspondent
we give a voice to communities often
unheard and unserved from a region with
a distinct history and global impact
i love my job because i get to do
something that is contributing to a
better future
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
are you ready to live with covid that's
a question facing our viewers panel and
studio guests tonight
from zoom quizzes to clap for carers
working from home and banana bread many
things became synonymous with lockdowns
and coveted restrictions
now the government wants life to move on
are there any positives from the last
two years that viewers panel want to
take forward
let's see what ron knocks
an old friend of the show uh ron in
surrey what uh what what do you want to
keep there's something that i think
sometimes we lose sight of over the last
two years which is how it's demonstrated
the character and the values of the
british people is become very evident
i mean if you look at
the army of volunteers that ensured a
successful
rollout of the vaccination they are the
real heroes of the vaccine out and
nobody else
and same with the people who work in
food banks and how much they've
contributed towards making sure people
don't stay hungry
just wanted to say that also i've seen a
and
over the two years an increase in
community spirit in my own neighborhood
we decided to congregate every sunday
morning on the curbside outside my house
and just in a socially distant way but
just support each other and be able to
share experiences of the week and and
feel that you're getting something
through you know
some some
contact between other people
now now we know if you want to be
cheered up on the sunday morning we're
all coming to your street but uh i think
i think the point about uh community
spirit's an important one uh patrice
wellesley cole patrice
um i think you
have taken some positives from the last
18 months as well
yes yes i have thank you trevor yes
lockdown gave me the opportunity to hear
from the best minds across the world
via zoom and teams
i could attend meetings i gave some
lectures and i also chaired meetings and
that was through organizations like bfwg
women graduates commonwealth lawyers and
commonwealth judges and cvp
i also became a rotarian and we had our
meetings online and as i live alone
and being lonely this did help patricia
it sounds like you just had a terrific
time in lockdown
well trevor i made the best of it um you
know i zoomed with friends in different
parts of the world i even went to the
zoom parties
but no it was very stimulating
intellectually because there's so many
interesting lectures and talks um online
as everything had to go online and
through my organizations like british
federation women graduates of peace and
security commonwealth lawyers and judges
and um un organizations
it was very intellectually stimulating
and the whole world was open to me thank
you um
let's talk to
hussein coasts um hussein
uh what did it do for you
uh good evening uh trevor uh it it gave
me perspective fundamentally
it um it allowed me to realize that
sometimes the small things are just as
important as the big things you know
particularly you know relationships uh a
cup of tea coffee waving at the neighbor
all of that was really really really
important to me and i'll be honest i
lost perspective of that so what's the
one piece of advice you'd give to your
pre-pandemic self
harriet minter
um
i think i would tell my pre-pandemic
self travel more
if she knew that she was going to be
living in her very small flat
continually for two years i think she
would want to get out and see the world
but also i don't feel that i prioritized
it enough before lockdown
and i personally am very much looking
forward to being able to see more of the
world now
aldo silly
spend more time with the family
my house was
pretty pandemic was a hotel for me i
used to go there sleep and go to work
spending three hours four hours a day
just traveling
i discovered zoom
and uh spending more time with my wife
my lovely nikki now is a business
partner from the pandemic that happened
and we started she started this um
business that is thriving
and everyone's happy
i'm not traveling and they see me
every day so i can't wait to go back to
work okay so travel
don't travel but going to business with
your wife or partner johnson assumption
well i shall want to do more of the
things that i've been prevented from
doing um over the last two years uh
and in my case also number one in that
list uh will be traveling
um i like traveling and one of the big
hardships and one i think of the most
unnecessary hardships have been the
border closures
okay so
get uh get uh an air ticket asuragani
what would you advise yourself well i'm
probably also on the on the travel side
of things um but working in this field i
think i would advise myself that it's
going to be so much more difficult and
go on so much longer than you can
possibly expect
john husseini sesh i'm going back to
our viewers because you've got a moment
here
and john i think you
had uh
some thoughts about what you've learned
having the opportunity to work in a
hybrid manner has been really beneficial
people have mentioned zoom teams which
we had to learn to use
um and working for a small um health and
safety business in uh in somerset we you
know we've been sending out newsletters
to help people understand what hybrid
working could look like because for many
of us you know um
it's not just the able-bodied but also
you know a hybrid working mode can help
those that may be disabled that may have
had an accident you know may have
elderly um relatives to look after
so you know to be able to have that
opportunity to work
um you know in in a home-based situation
working smarter not harder not burning
up miles on the motorway stocking hues
burning fuel
it's been it has been a positive the
hybrid working this is your territory
harriet it is i mean i was pretty
pandemic i spent about 15 years writing
about the future of work and a good ten
of those going into companies and
telling them they could allow their
employees to work from home and nothing
bad would happen and it took a pandemic
to make them do it
but we've seen it now we've seen it's
possible and we can't put the genie back
in the bottle so i think now is about
companies understanding that actually if
they are going to take hybrid working
forward if they are going to allow their
employees to work from home they need to
work really really hard to make sure
they don't create a two-tier system
where we favor people who are in the
office over people who are at home
and where we ensure that we don't go
back to a kind of
all hours culture that we don't burn out
and if they can start to think about
doing that
then what we're going to see with hybrid
working is all of us being able to keep
those things that we've loved about the
pandemic and that will be exciting well
that's a good note to end the show on
because that's all we have time for this
evening
it just remained to me to say thank you
to our palmetto studio aldo zilli
harriet minter
jonathan sampson and azragani
of course it's you at home who are at
the center of this conversation and if
you'd like to be part of the program
next time get in touch email the great
debate at sky dot uk
for now i want to thank you all on the
wall on the viewers panel
terrific as always
we'll see you in seven days time and at
home keep talking we'll see you again at
the same time next week for the great
debate
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Music]
you